[Musique]
bon témoin une ville mal aimé qui depuis
des années tente de se refaire une
beauté
c'est un sport magnifique mais la
première chose que les gens voient sont
les déchets et il trouve le port
dégoûtant john gadret a souvent tendu
les touristes se plaindre de la présence
de déchets dans le port de bales témoins
en collaboration avec la ville les
différents organismes
l'ingénieur a donc créé cette machine on
l'appelle mister trashouille alimentée
par le courant d'eau et par l'énergie
solaire
mais structure achoui aurait recueilli
les déchets de la ville qui se
retrouvent dans l'eau si ces déchets
n'étaient pas ramassé il finirait dans
la baie de chesapeake et ensuite dans
l'océan atlantique mégots de cigarettes
bouteilles sacs de plastique contenant
du styromousse
on y retrouve deux temps et parfois
quelques surprises un kayak une guitare
et même un python s'ils sont faufilés
mais essentiellement ce sont des ordures
cavale cette machine et mr trash ou et
on a bon appétit
depuis 2000 14 mille tonnes de déchets
ont été recueillis ah bon témoin cette
machine est beaucoup plus qu'un outil
pour combattre la pollution par le
plastique
elle est en fait devenue une véritable
mascotte de la ville et de son port les
gens se souviennent d'une chose le jour
où on en récupère un certain alors quand
on a décidé de créer une bière annales
on s'est dit qu'il fallait l'a nommé
après le pit ont perdu adam lind quest a
contribué à créer ce personnage c'est
lui qui a pensé à ajouter des yeux à la
machine chandail bière peluche
il ya même un festival est une chanson
qui rendent hommage à mr trash willow
[Musique]
déjà la quantité impressionnante de
déchets amassés par mr trash où il a
poussé la ville à interdire
l'utilisation de contenants de
styromousse dans les restaurants le
genre de décision qui permettra
peut-être un jour à mr tu as chaud de
prendre sa retraite
[Musique]